hello everyone my name is nagajan
so i'm currently working as like a
scientist at sana biotechnology
uh i think i would start with a thank
you note for the lab route
uh for for providing this opportunity uh
it's my second talk at lab roots
yeah so the today's talk would be
development of
like potency assists or selling gene
therapy so before i move on to the next
slide i want to really
briefly introduce you to this picture
here so this picture actually captures
most of the biological uh biological
pharmaceutical therapeutics around um
that has been
applied as therapeutic so
you start with the look at the
complexity how it really grows so you
see a small molecule
and when you go start looking at a
peptide and then you go into an antibody
to conjugate
um as you move on to like recombinant
proteins and antibodies they grow in
size and the complexity grows
and as we talk about cell and gene uh
right now you're looking at
a virus particle here and cell itself is
like around
one micron so you can understand how the
complexity
of these products have increased and
like how much uh kind of like
analytical development is really
required around these assays
around this product so i just want to
start
my presentation to giving like this
confidential statement
uh the reason for this one is kind of
like so most of
the data i'm presenting here data are
kind of like
uh are individually from my
knowledge that has been gained through
literature
uh i don't have any confidential
information in this presentation
it's just completely educational purpose
only
so please uh it's kind of like my
thoughts
uh if you have any questions on like any
of these like
i i'll be happy to you know uh provide
information where i get the information
from but like yeah don't
take these information and like assume
things
are always right because literature
changes and right now the literature
what i gain is is at present time
so okay the overview of the talk
would be like the outline of the talk
would be really is to introduce you know
cell and gene therapy products which
have been currently approved and what
what really
seven gene therapy uh products are
and really jump into how analytical
method development is involved in drug
product life cycle
and then you like as the talk itself
mainly focus on potential so i would
love to introduce to
fda guidance for developing these
potency essays
and really talk about the challenges
like
why potentials is so challenging for
cell and gene therapy products and
briefly touch on like two case studies
and i'll try to introduce like uh one in
gene therapy one in cell therapy
and how product uh how potentialities
have been developed around
it and finally the thoughts would be
really to
show some literature and talk about like
where how do you really if you want if
you want to really develop
a potency essay uh what's the way you
start looking at based on your
analytical development
so that that will be my closing
statement so
moving on
to as i said selling gene therapy
products
so the image here pretty much
shows you uh two kinds of products which
is like a gene testing product and the
self testing product
so the image on the left hand side when
you really look at like
the gene therapy product what really is
kind of when we get when we say a direct
delivery
so this can be a plasmid this can be a
viral vector so right now we have the
samara navigation circle where these are
also considered as kind of like
uh vaccines uh which almost mimic the
gene therapy product
so what you ideally do is like you can
use the plasmid itself
as a product or you can actually use a
viral vector to carry your plasmid so it
can be
ideally injected in vivo directly uh to
the specific site of your
uh region where you want to get your
selective region uh
like the therapeutic effect and then you
kind of get your
efficacy so when you look at like cell
survey products
uh it's kind of like cell therapy right
now what we are seeing here is
an example of a climatic antigen
t cell but in cell therapy you ideally
have
like an ipsc cell line terror products
and
and you start editing those to create
your specific self
so a simple example would be you you use
your specific transgene or a specific
therapeutic gene you want to introduce
that into the cells
so you can use through a vital vector or
you can
use through a non-viable vector which
can be out operation
or there are uh other methods which uh
which are known viral
and once you create kind of your
specific cell
through this transaction process you
kind of like
grow them up and get your enough
quantity
and you look at the potency of these
cells and then introduce them
into you into the human body for
therapeutic effect
so okay so when you look at
like on the left side i just put like
two examples of teen therapy products
that have been already approved and
they're in market right now
uh one is kind of like lextrana
and uh joel's and
dozens and it's kind of like av
no associated viruses these are have
been a common viral vectors that have
been approved for the market
and where uh the first one
is for the retinal disease you topically
apply this product onto retinal disease
whereas for the aav it's a
for the smooth muscular atrophy
when you come and look at like cell
therapy products you have chimera uh
kimraya which is like the acute
for the acute lymphatic leukemia
and escota for the b cell lymphoma so
it's kind of expected that like uh by
2030
they will be like around 60 to
30 to 60 gene therapeutic cell cell
products like treating patients
so like before we talk about potency
essays
i would like to introduce like the a
drug product lifecycle
and analytical development how
analytical development plays a key role
in this
process so
for the tech development process ideally
you start as a pre-clinical
once you have an idea you start with
pre-clinical
and you kind of like move on to phase
one phase two phase three
and at phase three is kind of real
getting your drug
uh through approval and you go for
market
and you kind of put the same in kind of
like a development
developmental cycle uh the pre-clinical
and phase one to phase two are still
considered as early phase
every state development that's where you
kind of work with your r d
and you're doing all this initial uh
transfer to kind of like looking at the
safety of the product and
efficacy of the product and once you
move into late stage it's kind of like
bigger clinical trials where you really
understand
the drug for multiple populations and
really look at efficacy
and get like more data on that once you
have good efficacy you go into like
commercial
so you can also look at the same life
cycle
based on kind of manufacturing so you
look at manufacturing what we
see is like initial all
is called as research and development
once you have a good
product you move into like engineering
gmp runs
and as you go into phase three it's kind
of they call it like clinical
uh good manufacturing and then
once you establish your methods for
manufacturing your drug
you move into commercial manufacturing
at this stage you already have like a
bla file and you got a good approach
from
fda and you look at the same
cycle on an analytical end so
analytical and pretty much like all the
pre-clinical and the phase
one is completely like you spend a lot
of time really
it's kind of defining the essays and
designing this
evaluating them and optimizing them and
once you really optimize you find
like the right uh kind of parameters for
the essay to really
give you the right uh output you kind of
qualify the essay
in which like you know the qualification
normally happens for phase one
and once you qualify these essays really
understanding
the specificity linearity accuracy of
the essay
you kind of move into like validation
which is primarily important for the
phase three
uh where you kind of like really
understand the essay of
i say robustness and like you start
testing like
uh really defining the criteria of the
essay like
where does this essay acceptance
criteria really play
and you really stringently log them up
for validation
and then once your drug went to
commercial you always do a verification
so it's kind of like you always
run the essay in the same conditions and
you have
always have an acceptance criteria and
the essay has to work in that acceptance
criteria
that's kind of verification so
the complete product drug product life
cycle
and analytical development looking from
it
that product side and once
you want to look at like from a cell and
gene therapy product
so what are the critical quality
attributes from an analytical
standpoint we ideally look for
so for the selling gene therapy product
these are complex products
so what fda has suggested is kind of
like
you know they we kind of have
class attributes and there is a quality
attribute so a class attribute
really defines uh what is the parameter
you need to identify
whereas the quality attribute really
gives you is kind of like
what is that specific to that attribute
of
class attributes so the first one would
be
really is kind of identity so when you
have like a
cell or gene therapy product you really
have to identify
the product itself so a simple example
would be okay you have
like an adreno associated virus so you
kind of really understand
the why this genome and the phenotype
let's come so it has
multiple serotypes so you say like a we
do
you really understand the phenotype is
like av2 through a specific protein
technology like using elisa
and you also look at the genome so the
genome identity is like okay you have a
specific transgene in it
so you ideally use pcr technologies to
really show that like your
specific product is getting the exact
crime scene
and the phenotype so the identity itself
is almost every time is product
specifics because you change
your transgene and your serotype
so the second attribute is kind of like
the purity and impurities
so when you create this your cell or
gene therapy product
ideally you don't want to really put
like a like a you you always have to
really put a pure product into uh
pre-clinical
form talk studies or kind of like
clinical studies so
at that point like what we are really
looking at here is really
understanding what is the product
quantity how much pure is your product
is like again coming to the same uh
using
an aav as an example here so what you
really look at is like
okay how many uh the production
particles are like how many of them are
full
or empty and then you start looking into
kind of like
is the product aggregated or like what
are the other
impurities that the product brings it
during the whole
festival process or the production
process so there are different methods
actually so
one the genomic method pcr based methods
are completely
heavily used and protein based uh
methods
are heavily used in in this case and we
also use like
multiple physical methods which i
ideally identify the size of the
particle
so based on like dls is one example
where people use
a lot to really define the aggregation
so so the purity and the impurities
are a play a very critical role a simple
guidance fda gives
is like once the product is going
into like a clinical uh a clinical lot
so what they claim is like you should
ideally have like 10 nanograms of dose
uh less amount of like dna
so what it really means is like a
the product should be pure enough in
such a way that like whatever
external residual plasmid or coastal dna
should be less than 10 nanograms per
dose
and they also look at the size of the
fragments that are really floating
around they should be below 200
base space so here again this is what
fda
gives and this might change these are
the guidances for now so these are most
of the guidances
we get from like the antibody field
so and the other area
when you have this product a of 17 would
be safety
so in which like you kind of really look
at like
you know you're not really adding
uh the clinical lot itself doesn't carry
any of the microbial contamination
that's where you again
use kind of like pcr based methods
genomic
pcr based on the protein methods and
microbial growth also
so in which like you really are looking
at like
endotoxin is a critical thing you look
at like and microplasma so microplasma
so these are all produced
in mammalian cells so you have a chance
of like microblastic contamination
and when you look at cell therapy
products you you you
ideally want your cells to be like
not oncogenic or tumorogenic so they
should be like
you should have a specific pcr based
method to show that like your cell
product is safe and where most of your
cells
are not tumorizing so
potency is a very critical attribute so
where it really defines kind of like the
exact
uh the stability of the product to
produce a therapeutic effect
so in that case normally there are like
different
genomic methods pcr is one of that and
you have a lot of cell based methods
here
so some of the quality attributes
given out would be like for gene therapy
would be the function or title
of the vector a specific transient
expression
for cells or the biologic activity or
kind of like the efficacy of the product
itself when you really
look at like uh a thought itself like
you really look at like how much
uh activity they can show to kill like
these
uh receptor specific activated cells
so again this is guidance it's always
like product specific
and product quality also plays a very
important role so you ideally want to
have
like your appearance like the ph and
those modality
are a few things you really look at like
and
we normally use like physical physical
methods to really determine that
so your ph guidance from fda would be
like 6.5 to 8 when it goes into a
clinical lock
so for today's talk we'll focus more on
potency actually
so so
like fda provided a huge document
uh for potential how do you design
potency assays for the
cell and gene therapy products so i kind
of like looked into that
and really picked up uh important texts
like
the first things you can really see is
kind of like uh
what does fda really define potency as
the specific
uh so they claim assets as a specific
ability or capacity of the product
uh as indicated by appropriate
laboratory tests
or you know when you go into control
clinical
data so it the product itself has to
give
the intended result from a therapeutic
efficacy based
result so so the
they they so you always start your
potency as a development
in early phase of clinical institutions
because like you
ideally put a lot of time in early stage
development
you have a lead candidate you do some
form initial
proof of concept studies so that's where
you try to understand
uh is your product really valid uh
to be a good candidate for
further time investigation so
what fda says is like you must
initially start collecting all the data
like the identity quality purity
strength and stability of this product
at all phases
of your clinical study even your in your
form talk studies you should have your
most of
these critical attributes being
collected uh
if you want to take a specific product
and really look at potency later
so again so as i said
cell and gene therapy products are very
complex so
it's it's much easier to define potency
for an antibody or a recombinant protein
but like
for cell and gene therapy it's it's very
complex because like it's just
the amount of biological attributes that
play a role
in defining the product of work is is
very complex so that's the only reason
so a simple example would be
if you have a gene therapy product you
kind of like
it has to go through two biological
activities right so
one would be like the gene itself
had to be transferred to your specific
cell of interest
and the cell of interest has to start
producing your specific protein and
that's where
you're really getting your potency out
so it's
it's multiple steps like it's not a
strike straight away product
like a straight away way to define uh
like it's not so easy to define straight
away
so as i said like
the biological attributes play a very
important role
in potential essays so
like where does potency really stand
when you want to really develop when you
have a
product development so you have a lead
candidate and you
you really want to understand the
potency aspect of the lead candidate so
ideally there are two areas like you can
subdivide
potency uh is like
kind of like understood so one would be
really
is kind of the initial characterization
when you start really
characterizing your drug product
what you really do is kind of you do a
lot of
you look into a lot of orthogonal
methods uh a simple example here
would be like you know when you're
looking at a viral vector product you
really define it
from kind of like a physical
title point of view you're looking at
maybe some other genomic dna that title
is carrying
and at the same time you will also look
at from a functional aspect how does the
vector itself is able able to really
uh transduce the cells and give you a
specific
uh result so at that point like you will
be
looking at like different orthogonal
method and then you kind of like
finalize a one of one or few methods so
the characterization which normally
happens in the early stage
will kind of really define what would be
the
how do you define potency in the later
stages that's what it really means
so and as said the potency should
always from fda guidelines potency
should
always be a quantitative measure of
biological activity
a simple example would be like if you
have a viral vector
you put it do a transaction you have a
specific gene of
expression let's consider it may be a
green source and protein
expression of green fluorescent protein
is considered to be
that output where you start you can
understand
the potency from the transduction
so the initial characterization and
initial potential determinations or like
they
kind of like work in tandem
and once you move and really move on to
like
really so once you define the product so
once you're done with the early stage
and you have a product
which is good to go and at that point
like
what really comes into play is kind of
you have to really look at like
three different aspects of the product
the first one would be
like the specifications and
where you really look at is the
stability and the comparability so when
i mean stability
so is the product itself what you
prepared
is stable enough and really it maintains
its potency or not
so does it really after like long-term
storage
can the product act as it's initially
produced
that's kind of that really means a
stability
so it's very complex for this selling
gene that products because like
this these are complex products these
are not simple proteins
so these stability studies play a very
important role for
potential determinations for uh lot
releases
and again so these studies also really
help to define the product consistency
and the process itself so
uh the way you're purifying the product
do you need to change anything to
increase disability these are all
questions that comes into play
when you're really dealing with cell and
genetic products and
comparability so comparability is kind
of like you have kind of like
released a lot but later what you
observed was kind of like
uh you change the process so
you have to have kind of this
product uh you have to save them in such
a way that like you're comparing
lot a to lot b because of the different
processes and showing them
they have the same potency in such a way
that like you can submit this
documentation
for fda to really show that like your
product really
the process doesn't really affect the
product itself
so the critical communication for
potency always comes from this in vivo
studies
where the efficacy and the in vivo
effect of the product itself once you do
initial proof of concept studies or then
you start doing
some kind of like um when i say
like proof of concept and from a formula
from top studies you really understand
is kind of like
what is the right dose of this
g7 genetic products where that you get
like a very
good kind of like therapeutic benefit
so the dose itself is always
undetermined with this
interview products because of uh
because of the the pro the
product how the product will act in vivo
is always
a good challenging area for the selling
gene that we product
and the most important thing of like
early development as process development
as
and the in vivo is really you need to
understand the mechanism of action
of the specific product so what fda
really requests is like you
really need to understand the mechanism
of action of the product
to define the potency so uh in
in in case like you you're not able to
give them
the right information of the mechanism
of action
the product might not get the approval
as needed
so potency is heavily dependent on the
mechanism of
action of the product so it's ideal to
really
define that mechanism of action from the
initial stages itself try to understand
the mechanism for action because as i
said gene typical products or cell type
products are complex and they have to go
through
these biological attributes so the
mechanism of action is always complex to
understand
but it's it's it's ideal to define a
good potential
so what are the desired characteristics
for a potential essay
so as i i showed you was kind of like
where does the potency aspect fit in the
whole
product as uh product development so
there's a couple of uh interesting
like attributes that should be really
taken into consideration
for potential essay performance so
always as i said fda requests for like
qualitative results which is kind of
like they need
something kind of like measurable
results that's what they want and
you should able to always establish an
acceptance criteria
even in an early stage or in later stage
so that is very critical
for a potency as a performance and
as i said a batch to pass consistency
you prepared a lot
uh a lot b with a different process you
just have to show that like
your product is acting similarly with
both the lots and gives you the same
consistent
uh therapeutic benefit that's where
your potency is like more robust
and as i said i stressed this previously
but i want to say
so mechanism of action of the product
should be clearly understood for
potentially essay so
then it's much easier uh to get approval
predict so another one would be like so
you should have some kind of systems in
withdrawal
and in such a way that like you always
can
predict the efficacy a clinical efficacy
a simple example would be
most of the time when you look at a
self-sufficient product from
a a carti most of the
things we look at is kind of really
looking at the vector copy number as a
critical attribute as well as
you look at the production of kind of
like
you know cytokines and
that's where you have a high cytokine a
specific
value of cytokine can always correlate
very nicely with the clinical efficacy
on
in vitro system so
and sensitivity and specificity enough
to detect the changes
and degradation so your essay should be
able to show
in any long term study or like you do is
long-term
stability studies if the product has
been degraded
it really has to identify that uh from a
potency as a point of view
so that's very critical for long-term
stability long-term storage of the
product so you have an essay that can
really identify
the ability of the product and
another one would be so the
as i said when you have a cellular gene
therapy product you always
the purity always is not hundred percent
but
you really the potency essay should be
able to differentiate between the
product and the impurity so
it really has to show if you have high
impurities it should be
able to really show that like you know
uh
lower potency because of the impurity
presence
so that's what it really means so it
should be
very specific at the same time it should
really show you like if the product
purity is not really good
so there are multiple challenges to
develop these potency
assays so as i said
these potency essays for cell and gene
the raw material plays a very important
role so initially
right now there is not really
standardized
raw material still because the product
itself is a complex product so you have
to use
different sources of raw material
so there's an inherent variability of
starting material
and at the same time you really don't
have the appropriate
reference material and it's very hard
sometimes because you're really
creating a product specific
very so it's very hard to create like
reference materials for each
product so again the examples
where the in variability comes from
starting material would be like you
cancer cell therapy
it can be from donor so the donor
variability so you get a donor
for lot a a donor change of a lot b so
the variability can be there
again when you look at like ipsc cell
line which
is used to differentiate and create like
uh cell separate products your cell line
heterogeneity plays a very important
role
like that's very important it should be
clonal so that's a very important thing
and the other would be like when you
really look at
itself from virus production
you consider like a nursery virus or
anti viruses you you should be very
carefully understanding
the product itself because like you have
a product where you might have like
most of your packed aav
can have genomic dna so these are things
we should be understanding better
and another thing would be limitation
as i said you for potency ss you have to
have
law like storage of lots whatever you
produce
but it's a small volume that for single
dose
therapies so it's always hard to really
maintain these
lots a small volume of sample because
the wall
your your whole product itself
will be mostly sufficient for your study
so
it's it's the limitation itself is like
how much product you produce can be
completely used for
study so uh the production
itself is always a challenge to really
define the potential essay
and multiple activity agents so
so this comes from mostly like kind of
like a simple example
here would be like you
have kind of like cells which need
activation
so you might have to have other reagents
like peptides to keep these cells
active uh in a cell surface product so
it it it's very hard at in sometimes
because
the peptides or the quality of the
peptide can really
affect your potency essay so that should
be understood very better
and again you kind of like use multiple
cell cell lines sometimes to create like
a final product
so another would be multiple vectors a
simple example would be like you have
a transition a with an av and then you
have transient b
you need both of them to work in a
therapeutic uh
which gives a therapeutic benefit so you
just mix them and really
give them uh for the
to carry out the tribe so this should be
really understood better
and those are big challenges like for
kind of like
for potency essay uh another one would
be
like the complex mechanism action so as
i said it's multiple steps right so you
have to have your infection done
then the genome should be like uh
integrated to access to show the
expression so these are
each step itself can affect your
potency essay so they're like you just
have to understand
the right cell lines or right mechanism
of how your product really works that's
a very important area
and so as i said always
the in vivo weight of the product is not
always
the same so you can be using a
batch of mice and when
it can give you a good result but like
after like
uh you go to a second batch of mice you
might not get the same results because
like
the there are a lot of factors
biological attributes that can really
change
so again this
the way you give the product also plays
an important role like is it like
a very profit or it's going to be an
in-vivo
so these all things come into play
and another thing would be
immunogenicity let's consider like you
have always have
uh these products can always not be
tolerated by
uh this animal model so you we just have
to understand better
so there are like multiple challenges uh
for this potency as a development
so i'll i'll quickly jump into like two
case studies where one is from gene
therapy so this
this wrapper from amazon is from gene
therapy
so so what they the the pepper
was came out last year so what they did
here was like they kind of like
developed
an in vitro potency assay for
adversarial viruses
uh which specifically encodes a tram
scene that has the ability to reduce
bilirubin
so what they did here was kind of like
their initial
proof of concept studies have been done
in mice
and they kind of selected the aav
specific vector which has
the branch gene and
as to reduce the animal studies they
want
they wanted to develop kind of like an
in vitro potency essay
so the first thing they did was kind of
really
looked at different cell models cell
line models where
they can actually mimic the similar
situation that's happening
in a mice so
what they found was kind of like they
found a cell line which is
the civic cell hips
hu h7 cells which have the ability
that the aav8 can really transduce them
with the flow cyto
the transient expression was confirmed
through flow cytometry
and they also used a bilirubin
conjugation essay
to show that like the specific transgen
they are expressing was able to actually
capture the bilirubin that's
been provided in the media
so and what they really
claim was kind of like they correlated
nicely across different constructs at
the same time they also showed
across different vector loans so
the graph on the left what really shows
a and b
is kind of like there they tested two
different
constructs which is called cco1 and co2
and what they are really showing here is
that when you have a higher dose
both the wild type and the co1 actually
mimic has good theoretical
whereas the co2 which is a different
construct doesn't really
happen doesn't really work as expected
so the same kind of like uh
is mimicked in those two and in low dose
also and they went ahead and looked at
like the vector copy number
and they really see kind of like
the very low vector copy number i think
they looked at like
the integrations and they clearly show
like
it shows like higher integrations uh in
d
uh whereas co one really doesn't really
show
much and then they're actually showing
here
um e and f is kind of the in the invitro
potency
so what they did was like they took the
same
constructs and they applied them on the
invitro
system and what they're really showing
here is like
the co one really
mimicking similar to what you see in
in vitro uh in vivo efficacy so
so through this what they claim is kind
of like
whatever they see in vivo is nicely
correlated to the in vitro potency
on the cell system so
and they also they also showed was kind
of like they produced the same
different lots in two different
production systems
where they are showing like h uh
like htk suspension cell line and the
back low virus of this aav
and when they ideally kind of like sent
put them in in vivo they actually saw
a little bit of difference between both
the lords and which
ideally was picked up uh by the invitro
system
with this small increase so that's what
they are trying to
show here so at the end of the day what
it
what they claim is kind of like this is
kind of like an in-vitro potency essay
which kind of mimicking this viral
vector
which is very i mean this is a product
specific vector so that's what
uh we've been discu i discussed
previously so
you always have to look and identify the
right cell line
in such a way that like it will be more
applicable to
kind of your own product specific thing
so the other case study
i put up here from is from cell therapy
so this
was produced in this paper was produced
in 2019
where in this case what they really were
showing here is kind of like when you
really want to identify the potency of
this
primary antigen t cells uh people
really use is kind of like um
two different way use a killing essay
which is always not real time it's an
endpoint essay most of the time and you
also
have to use like label floor force to
really
understand read out the specific
killing activity and which normally
was found to increase the background
noise
so in this essay what they use was kind
of like
uh they use this ex excellence real-time
cell analysis system
and what is the way it works really is
kind of like you plate your
target cells then you go with your
effector cells which are your
car t cells and when ideally when you
have these cells
the chip on the bottom has
the ability to transfer less electricity
because of more cells have been sticking
to the cell
as the carti cells show the effector
function
and kill the regular cells
uh the higher ability of
current transfer happens and that's what
is mimicked
uh in this graph so you have like
a higher current transfer it's really
showing like affect itself
uh kind of like it just
shows everything died out so there's a
more high current being produced
so whereas the control it just stays
normal it doesn't really
uh no change in current that's what it
really means so that's that's what it
really means for impedance
so what they did here was like they had
a
mock trans used which is in blue color
and like the specific cd47
car t cells which has the ability to
identify pancreatic cells and kill them
up and
they're using t cells itself and they're
just using the
pancreatic cancer cell line itself so
when you ideally have the pancreatic
cell line
and your coty which is the cd47 you see
that whole
uh nice curve where the others
others are controls where you don't see
that killing activity
and they also use kind of the control
where
they kind of like media itself and cut
this elsewhere you don't really see any
uh kind of change in current so i mean
this is this is kind of like a very good
a simple in vitro potency essay that has
been developed
and this uh
the the one thing they haven't shown in
this paper was like how do you relate
this to the in vivo efficacy
of the cart itself and in the field
itself people
have mostly killing activity always
doesn't really
correlate to the in vivo efficacy most
of the time it's
kind of like your production of
cytokines uh
show that efficacy uh that's that's a
good relation in party field
so anyway so moving on
so i would finally end saying that like
you know
uh the potential asset development
timeline and strategy
where you want to really invest in your
strategy would be like as i said
you have three clinical phase one phase
three phase one phase two phase three
and commercial
and when you look at like an essay point
of view development qualification and
validation right
so when you really put the strategy for
potency essays what you
ideally have to do is kind of like you
know the first initial
development phase you kind of really
understand
uh till release of the drug understand
the expression
tree really understand uh is the
specific transition really expressed
uh for a viral vector or for a cell
therapy
you just have to understand is the
specific
transient is expressing and can it
really show
any kind of activity as you want to
qualification where
you kind of like you're into moving into
phase two and phase three
where you kind of come back and really
correlate everything back to your
mechanisms action
uh and that's where you say like okay
this is
the mechanism action or where the
potency is coming from
and then you always also show expression
of
of your transgene but when you go to
commercial and validation
you always show them mostly the
mechanism of action with potency
and that's where you really define this
acceptance criteria of the product
okay so this is the range where the
product is really
active and it will give you the
kind of your therapeutic benefit so
again potency essays are not easy
there are multiple challenges with the
cell and
kind of like the seven gene therapy area
and as the field evolves
we will kind of like establish more
good valuable controls for this
potential
so i have a bunch of literature here to
if anybody interested in it so this is
pretty much like
all the fda guidances when you want to
really develop potency essays
and finally i would end with saying uh
acknowledge the areas where i gained all
this knowledge from
through like my school in uh texas a m
university
lonzo and sana and yeah
thank you